hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone who submitted questions for
this week's Marvel Q&A so because
there's some extra special stuff going
on in Hollywood right now and Robert
Downey jr. just happens to be at the
center of it I'm gonna add some extra
stuff at the beginning of the video some
interesting Ironman stuff just developed
so right away biggest news in the
morning is Robert Downey jr. in his own
words is going to ride the Iron Man wave
into the shore so I'll explain what that
means before I get to questions also a
few announcements at the end of the
video just to start things off I wanted
to pose a big question to you guys that
you can answer in the comments how long
is it okay for an actor to play a role
or be a character not just in the movies
just just in general anywhere it's kind
of a trick question because with the way
media works today in the digital film
and television worlds things change so
much in the presentation in the way we
see things it's not the exact same thing
over and over and over again even if
it's the same actor playing the same
character like Robert Downey jr. as
Ironman in 2008 completely different
from the Ironman we're gonna see in age
of Ultron next year personally I think
it's totally fine just as long as the
way we engage with characters and actors
changes over time Robert Downey jr. is
just a really good example that in the
way he's doing things right now if you
noticed in the last couple of months
he's been promoting another film that
he's working on called the judge but he
just joined Twitter and he's got a
Facebook page where he posts a bunch of
original videos he's just developing an
audience on those platforms you know
places where people like you and me go
to engage with other people about the
stuff we love so yes we'll continue to
see Robert Downey jr. as Iron Man till
the end of time but because of all these
other new things that he's doing on
social media we'll be able to engage
with them and watch him grow as a person
our perception of him over time will
evolve just like he evolved as a person
which is what makes it so much more
interesting for me Stephen Amell who
does arrow is another good example he's
used the popularity that he's gained on
arrow to build a big audience on social
media to raise money he's even going to
be doing his own TV series pretty soon
it's just part of this big thing that's
going on in Hollywood now it's just
starting to catch fire in the last
couple of years where big actors you
know build a social following to push
their passion projects and share their
lives with us some people like famous
youtubers build the audience first then
they break into Hollywood some do it the
other way around like Robert Downey jr.
he just joined social media officially a
little while ago Vin Diesel's another
really good example to big Hollywood
actor develops large audience on
Facebook and uses it to create awareness
for his own personal projects he
actually did that with the last Riddick
movie he claims that his Facebook
audience is responsible for that movie
making money it's just this really
fascinating trend in Hollywood that I
personally find extremely interesting so
if you guys want to talk more about big
superhero actors you know using their
fame to do other small things just let
me know and I'll make more videos about
that kind of stuff now it's time to
answer some questions though so careful
for spoilers from this week's agents of
shield if you haven't seen the episode
yet I'll wait just a sec okay ready here
we go question number one Alex asks
could Fitz be aware he's hallucinating
Simmons and just be doing it to make
himself feel better I definitely think
that he knows that no one else can see
her like he's the only one that can see
her something weird is definitely going
on he does seem crazy enough that he
does not think he's crazy to be talking
to her like if you've ever heard the
saying crazy people don't think they're
going crazy I think he's completely at
the point of dissociation with reality
that he just accepts head Simmons he
knows she's there and he knows that
she's not real but he's just not
processing it I don't think that he's
faking anything I think it's just an
automatic defense mechanism that is
psyche conjured up to fill gaps in his
brains normal ability to function it's
like that part of his brain is just in
Auto defense mode and the rest of his
conscious brain just isn't aware of it
question number two j-mo asks do you
think the blue tahiti alien brought the
Ovilus to earth yes i also think that
the tahiti alien is the alien that was
in that box like the one we saw in the
tube last season being pumped for its
secret sauce was the same one they found
in the crash in 1945 they just kept it
alive to the point where they can
extract genetic material as they need it
that actually kind of makes me wonder if
they're gonna go back and get that alien
to get more information that would be
actually pretty freaky if they were able
to wake it up somehow I don't think it's
still alive I think it's like barely a
speaking of barely alive though question
number three Mike asks where is Isabelle
Hartley we did not see her body in the
casket
so what's going on there is they're just
leaving it open so that they can bring
her back if they want to if the
opportunity arises they're just leaving
it very open-ended I know everyone saw
that funeral scene but remember Nick
Fury got a funeral in Captain America
and Nick Fury met at his burial site so
do not assume that funeral equals dead
forever
it's not a guarantee we're gonna see her
again this year but Lucy Lawless said
that her contract left all possibilities
open question number four the mej asks
do you think that Coulson ordered
Simmons to infiltrate Hydra I don't know
about Coulson but I definitely think
someone told her to do it she is like
the shining beacon of goodness on the
team so I don't think that she be inside
Hydra unless it was for a good reason
it's totally possible that she went
rogue and did this all herself she could
be searching for something like advanced
tech or scientific information something
that Hydra has that she needs
Coulson apparently knows everything
though so regardless of why she's there
I think he knows I saw that everyone in
the comments was really hoping that she
was trying to get something to help fix
Fitz I don't know that that's the case I
do think that she's trying to get
something important though question
number five a Kwan yes asks do you think
we'll ever get spider-woman referenced
on the show I think it's a weird
situation where Marvel does not have the
rights to the spider-man universe but
they do have Jessica drew in
consequently Spider Woman there's a
mountain of legal rules about the use of
spider language in marketing materials
so if Marvel ever did bring her on the
show or referenced her in some way it
would probably be using her real-life
name like they'd say agent Drew or agent
Jessica drew I do think they're free to
use her but behind the scenes you know
like the executives pulling the strings
from afar might not want to create a
whole lot of marketing confusion with
Sony's movies so they might just hold
off on her question number six XM 188
asks do you think that they'll wait till
the finale for Skye to meet her father
no I actually think that they'll meet
before the mid-season finale and then in
that episode like the mid-season finale
don't set the device off or they'll
activate it somehow from a writer's
perspective you want
in the season with a metaphorical
explosion like some big oh moment
and then leave people wondering what's
gonna happen after the Big Bang goes off
it's just a technical device to keep
people interested in the show till it
comes back and I actually think that the
agent Carter plot is gonna overlap with
shield this year at least the obelisk
part of the story just because agent
Carter's gonna air and shield timeslot
while shield is on break and in episode
2 whenever Clark Gregg was using that
black box that Nick Fury gave him he was
showing him pictures of agent Carter so
I think there will be some overlap with
this obelisk storyline it's just a
really easy way for Marvel to keep
people interested in the shield
storyline and get shield fans to watch
the Asian Carter show they haven't
confirmed anything but I just think it's
a really easy way to get shield people
to watch agent Carter it's just by
crossing one of the big storylines over
wouldn't it be crazy if the Kraken
character also showed up in the agent
Carter episodes remember he was young in
the past he was young in 1945 just
something to think about
question number 7 Tim asks how did rain
in the doctor touch the obelisk without
getting hurt I didn't see Skye's dad
pick it up but it seemed like they
polished it or did something weird to it
that changed it because the symbols
seemed much more prominent based on what
they said in that scene it sounds like
the object has a will of its own and
allowed Raina to touch it I think what
we'll find out is that only certain
special you know are metahumans will be
able to use it like Skye for instance at
the same people that are able to handle
the Tahiti blood they'll be able to grab
the obelisk you should expect all that
to get explained in the episodes that
feature Skye's dad though that's gonna
be like his big storyline question
number 8 Moriah asks what if the
Clockwork Orange device in the teaser
for episode 3 was used to condition
absorbing man yes definitely I think
that Kraken and other Hydra people just
use that to make people do what they
want the big storyline T's for episode 3
is that Kraken is going after shield
agents and apparently brainwashing them
into becoming Hydra agents do not be
surprised if one or more of the big
characters this season turn out to be
brainwashed Hydra agents like general
Talbot I don't know necessarily that
that's where they're taking that
character but it seems like there's some
sort of brainwashing plot that they're
gonna be setting up so do not be
surprised if
ward or someone else on the show gets
brainwashed by the end question number
nine
Bruno asks what if the third faction is
aim that's actually really interesting
Baron von Strucker created aim in the
comics after World War two they didn't
really go that direction in the movies
so it's hard to tell
shield typically does draw from
storylines set up in the movies though
it's a weird situation because an Iron
Man 3 aldrich killian claimed he created
aim I don't think that he was Hydra so
they could just be mixing and matching
storylines I'd really like to see Skye's
dad be part of a new organization or he
doesn't even have to be part of an
organization he could just be off on his
own thank you so much everyone for
submitting questions these are always a
ton of fun to do remember episode 3 is
next week so be sure to subscribe to get
my video if you're just finding me for
the first time here are a few schedule
changes that are happening next week
though flash and arrow are going to be
starting next week Tuesday and Wednesday
because I'm posting flash videos Tuesday
nights first my shield videos won't post
so way later after that so like 1 or 2
a.m. Wednesday mornings Pacific time so
just adjust based on which time zone you
live in don't worry I'm still doing all
the same videos there's just some extra
stuff happening next week and I'll
remind everyone again right now though
you can click here to get my episode 2
video and click here for my episode 1
video thank you so much for watching so
that's all high five and I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you